you know you watch people throw a
football when you're a kid and you go I
want to throw it like that I saw Joe Coy
start selling out clubs and everything I
was like I'm gonna do it like that but
then when covet hit
I just couldn't move anymore for a while
so I just sat out and I noticed it just
works for me hot breath how long have
you been up I've been doing it 13 years
and you like it do I like it comedy oh I
love it yeah yeah when the first time
you were on stage how'd you feel the
first time you ever got up oh that was
it was heroin
I mean like oh well I thought you said
you were on heroin I was like wow that's
an experience right there no it was just
like as soon as I did it I was like oh
this is what I'm doing the rest of my
life see me too I called my mom yeah
first time I was on I go this is what I
was born to do yep instantly born to do
but my mom always knew she would always
thought that I would go into like
something in entertainment entertaining
things yes okay she wasn't surprised but
it was
definitely the idea of doing comedy and
then actually getting on stage are kind
of two different things yeah see I was
never funny
so I'm not in real life I mean you can
ask all my boys I'm not a funny dude in
real life like it's just
I know how to tell stories I'm gonna
start like I'm more of a I'm not a joke
writer I'm a storyteller
but the stories I tell there's a lot of
funny things that happen in them or are
heighten it like any comic you kind of
heighten it I'm just lucky to have
interesting things happen in my life
where they're funny but that's Joe Coy
told you to heighten it right well joke
right jokes he said for me for me
because he knew I wasn't he goes if you
ever sit down to write a joke stop sit
down and write a story and make that
story funny
wow and that's the best and and then the
other piece of advice was that I came up
with on my own just experience people
outgrow jokes but they don't outgrow you
you know what I mean like they don't
like like
jokes are one thing but after they hear
it
it's kind of done and you make them feel
a certain way which is amazing but if
they're connected to you
and they really are invested in you in
your life
I feel you become a real life sitcom to
them but I've heard you recently say
that you just now like found your voice
I did like you just so what what because
this is something I'm still trying to
figure out so like what clicked for you
was it like certain topics or certain
ways you were saying no you know what
clay for me when I first started Joe Coy
was my mentor so everywhere I would go I
was like oh I want to be like Joe Coy
you know so I did a lot of back and
forth on the stage and and then I got
covet almost died yeah and then I
remember when I started before I didn't
have the energy for that so I sat down
and then when I sat down I noticed my
material for me was hitting harder and I
saw people pay way more attention
because I wasn't for me I wasn't trying
to put on a show I was just like hear my
jokes and trying to connect you know and
yeah you could do like Joe Coy connects
with everybody but that wasn't my thing
it was like I found my voice
but he was so strong in my upbringing of
Comedy I was trying to Not Duplicate him
but he's my inspiration you know you
watch people throw a football when
you're a kid and you go I want to throw
it like that I saw Joe Coy start selling
out clubs and everything I was like I'm
gonna do it like that but then when
covet hit
I just couldn't move anymore for a while
so I just sat out and I noticed it just
works for me so it's like a rhythmic
thing that just changed you know I don't
know I think I slowed down I think it
for me
it just became about it was my zone
because I was a radio Dude too you know
so I just feel like I just tell stories
I just tell stories and that's my thing
and for me telling a story looks and
works better on me when I'm sitting down
gotcha and I like it I feel weird
standing up now
and I want to get back to Joe Coy
because I feel like especially in the
comedy world the definitely the old
school mentality was very like
competitive and negative yeah it was
when I just started 12 years ago oh okay
oh man people hated comics and people
I can't tell you how many people talk
[__] about Joe when I started like like
he's not a comic he sings at the end but
I go I just I just I go I saw him just
Crush for an hour and a half
you know without singing so and when you
leave I've never he was the first one I
ever experienced leaving a show and it
felt like this when he was doing clubs
too leaving his show and it felt like
you saw a rock concert it felt like you
didn't just leave going ah that was fun
you left with an experience and he's
doing that in stadiums too whether it's
bringing up Boys to Men or the material
crushes but then it gives you a little
extra and he was doing that 12 years ago
yeah that's it's so important to have
like a some someone to support you or
someone that can like you can bounce
ideas off of and like be like Oh I'm not
alone in this comedy grind where it's
like oh I'm driving 12 hours for fifty
dollars yeah I did all that yeah yeah he
was my mentor and he took me on the road
but it's kind of like he wouldn't take
you if you weren't funny so you had to
be funny first so I I drove to three
four hours for Nothing free a lot of
times from LA to San Diego from LA to
wherever to find free spots and then in
L.A it was hard to get up you know I I
was lucky I got up because I was on TV
so but still you don't get the same time
as when you get experience you know what
I mean so yeah man it just worked out
but I I love comedy I love the rawness
of it I love I love that it's just you
so it's it starts and ends with you and
then you can see the rise and then you
can see it's so humbling you know like
for instance tonight I meant this cup
sold out the first show but this next
show is gonna be like last time I
checked tickets it was eight people
eight eight and that one was just sold
out stimulation sold out but that's what
I love too because now I'm like okay if
there's gonna be eight people or however
many show up now I can do a different
show and maybe bring some people on
stage just now like I could just really
connect with those because they paid
money I'm their night out so it doesn't
matter to me if they're sold out or
eight people or however many show up
they're gonna get the best show because
that's what they I'm somebody's not this
is what blows me and this is what I love
about com I am somebody's night out
and that's so humbling like you're their
night out they pay their money they're
gonna buy drinks they're like mark it on
their calendar like oh we're gonna go
see this person and I think you can't
ever lose that because I think yeah
everybody goes through the thing we're
like oh here's another show or I gotta
go to another city but you work so hard
to get to that point where
you know I'm not even to the level of a
lot of comics you know obviously by the
eight people they're gonna watch me in
the next show but what's great is those
eight people paid money to see me fine
with me guess what I'm a I'ma know every
one of their names before they leave
which I can't say for the first show it
seems like mindset is a big part of
Europe for me yeah because it doesn't
matter man I came from not doing comedy
to be able to
feed my family doing something I love so
yeah you're gonna and it's so humble I
think that's important you know no comic
is great till they jump to that next
level you know we're all the same you
know we make a little bit more money but
you'll see the next nobody's gonna be
out there and I'm fine with that because
I know you got to go through that to get
to the next level you know and you build
like I'm shooting my own documentary
right now that's why you see all the
cameras yeah
because I wanted to show people the ups
and downs like on Instagram you just see
sold out
you know you're not going to see eight
people nobody's gonna post eight people
that came to your show because people it
would break their Miss they would break
their conception oh this dude's always
selling out you know but no I want to
show everything because
the point in my career right now and I
got a long way to go
I'm not trying to be funny to everyone
Whoever likes me I'm trying to Super
serve them
because then eventually other people
jump in I'm just trying to make stuff
and fund my own stuff that my audience
will like and I feel my audience will
like
you know if I do well this journey of me
going to different cities
and really seeing how it is and you bet
on yourself which is 100 it's kind of
the new wave in comedies it's like well
we just you got to create it all
yourself nobody's gonna do it for you
you do because
the thing is so many people want to tell
you no
it's easy to say no one of my friends uh
I remember she gave me the best she's a
big casting director her name is Alyssa
she gave me the best piece of advice she
goes in Hollywood this has nothing to do
with comedy just in Hollywood no one
ever wants to be no one ever wants to be
the first yes hmm you know but they
always love being the second third and
fourth yes you know what I mean so my
thing is to me the audience
is the key to all this so instead when I
shot this special my last special
um
uh I never thought
my agent was like you want to take it to
Netflix and all I go no I want to take
it to the people why get frustrated and
it could have and I'll be honest it
could have been on Netflix who knows but
I didn't even give it a chance to fail I
go I want to do it pay for my own do it
the way I want to do it and put it out
and at the time I only had 3 000 YouTube
followers wow which is in business sense
I was just I was so hungry to put out my
own thing and Joe said you got to bet on
yourself so I was like all right put it
out
and now I'm at 155 000 on YouTube in
just a year and my Facebook went from 60
000 to now I'm like 560 000. and it's
all for my special generated all that
answers wow now it's a business for me
you know now I take part of the budget I
make and I bring a camera guy to shoot a
DOT because I'm like all right I am my
own business now I need to keep
expanding I'm not going to get lazy I
want I want to take people on the road
with me I want to show them this and I
got the idea from formula one from
Netflix you know to see these drivers go
to different cities I go that's common
that's what we do you know and I want to
show you know like the number honestly
the numbers of tickets I sold when I
went the year before going in and then
the number I sold coming out so people
can really see if I'm growing or not in
certain oh I love that you know like La
Jolla I did that uh last week sold out
four shows
but last year about a year and a half
ago I went there I sold out one so it's
a great story Ice House opened back up
sold out too
so you have this great run of selling
out every weekend in Atlanta
sold out the first one eight people
you know what but that's
that's exactly and that's what I want to
show yeah you know and then it's just on
the road missing your family like I
missed my I dropped off my kids on their
first day of school my son's been going
to school so it wasn't a bit but it was
my daughter's first time going but I
didn't get to pick her up because I had
to get on a flight to go to Nashville so
I want to show that kind of stuff I just
want people my parents have become big
like do a podcast with them so I want to
put them in it so and I want to fund it
all yeah and when you think from the
business sense it's like how can you
differentiate from other comedians in
the market and that's that's what I'm
trying to figure out right now is it's
like I'm a comedian I'll do like Road
gigs I do like comedy zones and things
like that right now but it's also like I
have this podcast so it's like it's kind
of like my attention is split in two
ways almost where it's and I'm kind of
like doing each kind of halfway so think
in a business sense it's almost like
going all in on one and I feel like my
differentiator is this podcast but in my
comedian mind it's like when I'm a
comedian and I wanted no but but see
that's the difference you can do both
yeah because you don't look at it as two
separate things
people always ask me what do you love
most do you love hosting do you love
acting or do you like comedy and to me
it's entertainment it's the same thing
there's no difference you know it's a
different skill but that's like going to
a chef at Chili's and going do You Like
Making burgers better fish better or
tacos better he's like I'm just cooking
so when people say I'm saying I'm just
cooking I'm cooking three different
things right now you know it's all the
same don't differentiate you're gonna
have more success than of it but that
it's still entertainment and the big
umbrellas entertainment so want to pop
off
and then like like for instance a year
ago before my special came out if I
would put a video on my Facebook page
like a podcast it would get 100 views
now I could go on there and go
for two minutes you know it will get
probably like six seven thousand views
you know what I mean because you're
finding people that are interested in
you gotcha so this podcast is going to
reach people
uh that are fans of other Comedians and
hopefully on the same page you're
putting little clips of you or something
that your comedy because that's the
whole thing and I'll tell you one last
thing is like
I have a friend
exploded on social media you know but it
was exploded in doing something that he
doesn't do on stage he exploded
interviewing not interviewing but like
giving money and different things like
that you know millions of views millions
of tick tock follows millions of this
and that but nobody comes to his shows
because people know him
for not stand up um
gotcha you know it's kind of like if you
make cooking videos all the time
and then he goes well come to my show
I'm gonna stand up and like no we know
you for this gotcha you know so that's
the thing is you you wanna that's what I
try to do is incorporate everything
around comedy and just for my fans I
don't try to make everyone happy anymore
because it's so subjective and it's so
now everybody has their own channels so
it's kind of like find your people find
your tribe I guess they would say and
just super serve over serve them don't
even worry about getting other comics on
your Saturday hey guess what if you keep
super serving these people they will
come you know what I mean so all right
so as we land This Plane
um a question I always ask on here yeah
is a comedian's worst like bombing story
or getting booed or just one of those
gigs my worst thing is when I did
colleges and I hated doing colleges
but I remember you know I was always way
older since I was on TV they booked me
but my content was like
so like I'm 15 20 years out of school
going to colleges you know so I remember
one I remember I was just talking about
being engaged at a college
and it's about 10 minutes in a guy
raises his hand nicest way it goes
but kind of dickish too he goes when are
you going to be funny
and then you know what I I kind of like
started roasting him and then I just
started roasting College people and it
was a great time it wounded up great but
that's the first time anyone said like
your performance sucks right now and it
was kind of a wake-up call because first
of all I didn't want to be there uh-huh
I could give a [__] less about colleges
and the biggest thing is I hate it
is I was at this thing called NACA where
they booked the comics
this [__] 17 year old girl
it still hurts yeah I said that was like
well we booked this comic and if we have
enough money we'll book you too like
snooty right
and I go
I'm at a point where a 17 year old girl
is controlling my career and telling me
my worth
I'm out and that's when I quit and I go
I'm going to control everything myself
and take it straight to the people I'm
not gonna rely on other people to give
me opportunities because they don't a
lot of times you will find great people
like Joe and different bird Chrysler is
always like you know like when my
special came out he promoted it and
stuff like you'll always find some
communities that promote you but you
can't wait for that you can't depend on
it you just do you and then once the
product is good other people react amen
well do you have any closing advice for
young Comics out there yes yes no matter
how many people in the audience rock it
like it's sold out and then you'll see
what happens man you know because really
it's about them and if those eight
people that are out there right now
those eight people out there if they
leave and love the show they're gonna
tell somebody so maybe I can have 16 for
tomorrow's Late Show well you know maybe
it'll grow maybe after this you get the
hot breath bump now boom maybe hot
breath bump is coming so where uh where
do you want people to like keep up with
you and like check out everything you're
doing what's the best you know what they
know they know because it's out it's my
name Michael Yo they know like if they
wanna like you if you tag it and put
anything they can search it but you know
like Michael Yo everything is Michael Yo
Michael Yo beautiful well thank you so
much for you just listening and you just
jumped in and did this I appreciate it
man appreciate you all right all right
appreciate it